you gotta know when to change tactics
okay so normally I would be loath to do
two videos relating to DC EU and DC
related movies in a row but as this
occurred to me a couple nights ago when
I was doing the record for one of my
podcasts go home Hollywood you're drunk
available on the council geeks Network
podcast feed and talking about one
specific thing got my mind spinning and
a lot of this I said in the podcast but
as I've done it before I have way more
viewers when I have podcast listeners so
I don't mind revisiting that thought a
little bit and possibly expanding on
now this spawned from something that was
said by Adam McKay who is currently the
director for the proposed Nightwing
movie now he was basically asked why
wasn't there anything shown at comic-con
I mean
Nightwing didn't even have a logo there
was nothing no announcement nothing at
all which struck some people as a little
unusual and I think while no one was
saying it outright some folks are
starting to wonder is this movie
actually going to happen so what Adam
McKay said was he actually put it in the
greater context of his career as a whole
and he said look there have been lots of
projects over the course of my career
that I have turned down mainly because
they came attached with already assigned
release dates meaning that I was not
going to be given the time that I may
need to make this work and it was going
to be a have a deadline forced on my
throat that is not the case with me
working on Nightwing that's why I'm
doing it so that was his way of saying
that Warner Brothers is not enforcing a
strict here's your here's your release
date you must hit this which we know
they did already with Suicide Squad and
I mean they're that's not exclusive to
them Fox has a massive history pulling
this kind of crap but this is a very
different approach that they appear to
be having in terms of what they are
granting Adam okay and one can start to
wonder and extrapolate because a number
of the major projects don't have release
dates we don't have a release date for
the neck
Batman movie we know they don't seem to
be getting as rigid about saying when
stuff's coming out just what they're
working on I don't think we've got firm
release dates on Shazam or the supposed
Black Adam movie either
there's some stuff that given us years
for but it's not it's not like say how
Marvel is them which is get it whenever
Marvel announces a project they also
announced at the very least the year
that it's going to be coming out right
now Warner Brothers and with their DC
related projects has a whole bunch that
they've announced with no release dates
attached to the year and this I think is
a very good thing because whether or not
you feel this works better than Marvel
this is very different and what I'm
about to talk about and I think it is
good that Marvel and DC movies get
approached differently because otherwise
we end up with just homogenized product
across all all superhero movies and I
don't want that so what the DC related
movies have done even going back into
like Batman or arguably even Superman
though that was really a different era
of filmmaking but they had a tendency to
go after really big visionary people to
head these projects Tim Burton early on
they brought in Joel Schumacher when Tim
Burton kind of scared them a little bit
so that changed things to a certain
degree but then they brought in
Christopher Nolan to do Batman again and
they brought in Zack Snyder and whatever
you may feel whatever I may feel about
Zack Snyder is output the man's got big
ambitions he's not a guy that you just
bring in to just plug into the property
like say was what happened when they had
Martin Campbell come in to try and do
Green Lantern I like Martin Campbell as
the director but he's he's good at being
plugged into existing framework that's
why he's James Bond's are so good they
needed a more visionary director that he
can get one it didn't work so they seem
to be trying to recapture that approach
that serve them very well in the past
now when they got Zack Snyder and they
had you know Man of Steel and there's
some debate now it seems like how much a
b vs the theatrical release at any rate
was what snyder actually wanted to
release two films but i think even if
you want to argue that it was cut down
so that it was less coherent which i
don't question it seemed very much to be
his vision of the movie even if it was a
truncated version so it still felt very
much of his now David Ayer on Suicide
Squad we know massively messed with
across the board on that patty Jenkins
they left her alone to do Wonder Woman
so I think Warner Brothers is starting
to realize that whatever they've meddled
whatever the studio has gotten more
involved with more mandates and more
meddling that's when we've gotten stuff
like Batman or Robin Green Lantern
Suicide Squad that approach is not
working they need to back off they need
to stop imposing these kinds of rigid
gates and expectations if they're going
to continue to try and bring in
directors who want to bring their own
flavor are going to want to do their own
things like Adam McKay clearly wants to
do or like hopefully Matt Reeves will do
with the Batman now to contrast that
with Marvel Marvel brought in I'm not a
visionary might be pushing a little bit
Marvel brought in their people with
stronger specific artistic voices
earlier on the process you got people
like Kenneth Branagh on Thor and as
they've sort of gotten momentum and
moved along they've been turning much
more towards television people that's
where the Russo brothers came out of and
I think that's because Marvel has a very
clear vision and they know what they
want and they just want someone to come
in and give you you know give their
little touches but ultimately deliver
what they've already said they wanted to
be that's why a go right ultimately
bailed on ant-man because he wasn't
going to March so they're there to the
beat of their drum to the extent that
they wanted I still personally have a
feeling that the ant-man we got was not
they probably have a little less visual
style but it was probably not hugely
substantively different from what Edgar
would deliver he just didn't want to
work under the kinds of restrictions
that they were giving him now the reason
this is worked for Marvel as opposed to
DC where it is completely backfired when
they try to impose restrictions is that
Marvel has been courting people who are
used to working those circumstances
because when you get people who work in
television again like the Russos and
some of the other people they've gotten
you're getting people who are used to
being told here here is this existing
property with these existing characters
who are expected to behave in these ways
here's your episode to do with in this
greater framework and they just don't
have the expectation to lay in as much
of their own singular voice so Marvel
has been courting talent that works with
the way they are choosing to approach
the movies DC this is really backfired
on them because they were still courting
or you know trying to bring in people
with clearer artistic voices buttons
day-to-day or has a pretty clear
distinctive cinematic voice and yet they
restricted and handcuffed and through
all these restrictions that I'm like you
can't have both and this is part of
we're trying to rush into you know the
big cohesive Cinematic Universe really
hasn't been working for DC so here's
where I think this is a good thing where
it's going to it's an altering and it's
going back to something that has worked
for them more often because I've said
this before too I think that if DC can
get back to the structure which is the
more mentality that they got when we got
Tim Burton on Batman Nolan on Batman but
they just seem to do Batman better
anyway getting back to that mentality
and that approach can result in much
better individual movies I will still
attest as much as I love Marvel and I
love the MCU they have not produced a
single film that can even come close to
rivaling the Dark Knight and I honestly
don't think that they can but they have
a much more cohesive and flowing and and
appropriately interlocked cinematic
universe then DC has been able to build
I think DC needs to swallow the idea
that at Lee
at this point they can't do that it's
not playing to their strengths or leaks
the strengths that they've had in the
past because in the past as I said they
resulted in the best product when they
have gotten good people with vision and
just let them do their work Burton
Nolan Jenkins this is when they got
people and left them alone now it
doesn't always work as I said even
Snyder's better film that he did man of
steel I it was not universally loved
some people do love it and that's fine
but it was kind of a mixed bag reception
but still that was certainly better than
the reception too when they have really
gotten in there and meddled or put a ton
of restrictions on them because that's
when we've gotten Green Lantern Suicide
Squad so again this is a good approach
this is a good way for Warner Brothers
to start dealing with this here's what
has to happen though and here's where
I'm afraid they're going to get cold
feet or fall back into the mistakes
they've already made by allowing
individual directors more freedom to
craft individual films the way they want
to deliver them that is going to make it
much harder if not impossible to
interlock these films with anything near
the tightness that Marvel does because
the reason that Marvel is able to have
all these characters cross over left and
right and have everything line up in a
timeline and everything like that is
because it's all scheduled ahead of time
so they know when they need these actors
they know when the movie needs to be
delivered by all of this is already set
and then they get you know people from
TV or whatever who are used to working
under those circumstances and put them
into the r act but if DC is going to go
back to courting and then allowing the
freedom for directors to take as long as
they want they can't lay the same kinds
of plans that to try and have the same
level of cohesion that Marvel has
accomplished because you just can't do
that when you're allowing your directors
that degree of freedom and I don't say
that as a criticism I say that as a
reality if you have directors like Matt
Reeves like Adam McKay like patty
you need to give them the space to do
what they're going to do but that means
that you can't dictate to them when it's
going to be ready by and if you don't
know when it's going to be ready by that
means you you can't build that same kind
of cohesive cinematic universe because
you don't know for certain when this
movie's going to come out maybe this one
will be done first and this movie will
come out first and you won't know that
until they start going to production and
they've got to plan around that but now
things are already moving and it's
trying to get them into lineup and then
you get into over Medellin it becomes a
mess again I think that DC needs to back
up and I'm not saying abandon a
cinematic universe but they need to
really back off the idea of trying to do
anything as tightly controlled as Marvel
is doing because it's not working for
them and I'm hoping that Warner Brothers
has the awareness or at least has gained
the awareness to do that so if they do
if Warner Brothers can get to the level
where they go look we need to back off
the cinematic universe saying we'll
still you know they'll still be some
crossover we'll have Easter eggs or
whatever but we need to back off trying
to match the level of crossover that
Marvel is able to do very casually at
this point we need to get off that
expectation and I hope that they can do
that and one of the things that might
cause them to not be able to do that as
fans we need to back off the expectation
that DC will do that we need to look at
getting the best individual films that
we can because that is what potentially
DC can do maybe even better than Marvel
if they could start consistently
cranking out material and that's the
wrong term because crank comprises a
machine if they can get a wave of
machine and start consistently allowing
directors and creative people to produce
the best possible work that they can
then we could be getting individual
films that could potentially be better
than anything Marvel is putting out but
it's just not going to be the same level
of an overall universe and honestly
that's a balance that for me as an
audience goer I would kind of like I
think it would be cool to sort of look
forward to see what individual
DC movie they're doing while at the same
time over on the Marvel side getting
very wrapped up in the whole
interconnectedness of everything that
way I'm actually getting different
things from the different universes and
maybe if the friggin fanboys would get
off each others butts for a second it
would make them realize it's okay to
like both because they're each doing a
different thing where DC has fallen down
is in their attempt to catch up to
Marvel initially with BB F leaping right
into the mule getting as many characters
as we can into this lead jumping right
into the team up and then just trying to
exert a level of control that Marvel has
shown to have over directors that are
you know they're not built to just be
slotted into a machine directors with
vision need to be allowed to do their
vision so I really do hope that this
quote from Adam McKay and I've
extrapolated a lot from one quote from
one director it could just be him that
they're giving a lot of freedom to but
I'm more optimistic on one of others
these days they still got a lot of
goodwill they need to earn back from me
but right because right now a lot of
these things are in process and I'm
looking at the processes they're going
through ongoing these are smarter ways
to go a lot to go about a lot of these
things so you are indicating to me that
you seem to be getting better
the proof is ultimately going to be in
the pudding goes because I won't truly
be able to say they've won me back until
we get more movies that actually work
and are good finished products so I I'm
not like woo on DC but I'm certainly not
much more positive spot that I was what
I did that incredibly loud shouting
video saying how I wanted the DC EU to
fail I think that they may have found
the way forward that will work and that
quote from Adam McKay indicates to me
that maybe just maybe they've got an
office idea of we need to catch up to
Marvel and instead are going what do we
do that Marvel is not doing and do that
instead
and I hope that that's the case and I
hope that if that is what they do and
they focus more on doing the best
individual films and less on building a
huge universe that the fans will not
whine about that those are my thoughts
on what might be the future and a bright
future for the DCE you what are your
thoughts on this do you think that I'm
not spurred and for thinking that this
approach is good D do you think they
should be doing something else do you
think I have just completely presumed a
whole bunch of stuff and I am talking
out of my butt from Lord go whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geese podcast
which I already mentioned available on
iTunes and stitcher I'm also 1/2 of the
punch like a girl podcast also available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]